je pense qu'il ya des éléments du
capitaliste assez détestable et
particulièrement dans leurs formes les
plus sauvages on n'aura pas et la
croissance et finalement de la
stabilisation à l'amélioration des
situations sur le plan écologique va
falloir choisir on se rend compte qu'on
s'en va dans un mur si on ne fait rien
concernant dans un mur collectivement ça
fait 35 ans maintenant qu'on espère que
le développement durable nous permettent
d'améliorer la qualité de vie de tous
les humains de génération en génération
c'est vrai que l'auteur s'est améliorée
globalement mais jusqu'à maintenant le
développement économique s'est fait en
consommant plus d'énergie et de
ressources naturelles et en produisant
des déchets la pollution de quoi nuit au
bien-être des enfants d'aujourd'hui
d'ici quelques décennies si on inversait
la tendance s'agit pas seulement
d'aplatir la courbe ici mais de
continuer à générer de la richesse tout
en respectant la planète on appellerait
à l'orge complets le découplage mais
est-ce que c'est seulement possible
certains pensent qu'on peut servir du
système économique actuel pour limiter
et même renversé les dégâts et arriver à
une croissance verte d'autres sont
beaucoup plus sceptiques
des voix les plus fortes du milieu
universitaire à mettre en doute le fait
que puisse exister un capitalisme vert
c'est yves marie abraham il enseigne à
hec montréal
c'est vraiment étrange d'enseigner la
décroissance au futur jardin
pour l'instant ça c'est un constat
scientifique
nous n'avons jamais été capables de
générer quelque chose comme une
croissance verte ce fameux découplage il
n'a jamais été obtenues et il semble
qu'on soit très loin de l'obtenir parce
qu'on est capable de générer c'est ce
qu'on appelle un découplage relatif
c'est à dire que ça se dégrade un peu
moins vite que ça ne croit sur le plan
économique vous dit encore autrement
c'est leur par unité produite par
marchandise que vous produisez ont fait
un peu moins de dégâts mais comme on
produit de plus en plus de marchandises
au total les dégâts des dégâts s'aggrave
quand même quels facteurs font que la
croissance verte
vous n'y croyez pas il ya plusieurs
raisons ont fait un mois jean dauger je
les classe en trois grandes catégories
c'est émotif
il ya des motifs qui touche aux limites
biophysique planétaire en fait on a un
certain nombre de ressources dont on a
besoin aujourd'hui qu'on utilise et pour
lesquels on n'a pas vraiment de
remplacement premier problème deuxième
problème c'est ces fameux effet rebond
les faire ben c'est quand on fait une
économie d'énergie de temps ou de
ressources mais que ce gain la ramène
pas de réelle amélioration
parce que ce qu'on a gagné sarah
produire encore plus ou à offrir un prix
plus bas qui mène finalement à une plus
grande consommation par exemple les
moteurs des voitures dans les années 70
et 80 et et gourmands en carburant on
les a rendu beaucoup plus d'efficacité
du temps sauf que ce qu'on observe c'est
que l'économie grenier en réduisant
consommation de carburant est en fête et
investit dans des trajets plus longs ou
sarah acheter des véhicules plus gros
plus luxueux ou à se payer des activités
énergie voix ou bien tout somme et en
plus on est efficace lui on veut en
faire plus
mme additionne finalement les ressources
qu'on utilise plutôt qu'on les
substituts les unes aux autres et puis
la troisième limite basse et c'est
finalement les limites politiques ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont les plus gros
destructeur sur le plan écologique sont
aussi ceux qui ont plus grand pouvoir
politique ils sont donc en position
finalement d'éviter des limites à leur
destruction ou alors de transférer ses
coûts à d'autres salariés ou à l'autre
bout du monde et c'est donc parce que
politiquement ils ont cette capacité
les arguments d'yves-marie abraham sont
super convaincant mais ça reste un peu
théorique je m'en vais rencontrer
quelqu'un qui avait commencé une
carrière en science mais qui maintenant
et tout des femmes d'affaires les plus
influentes au pays et l'oeuvre en
technologies propres
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux gens qui
disent comme si le système ne change au
il est fondamentalement comme ont pu le
bout je suis parfaitement d'accord avec
eux c'est conserva vers l'épuisement des
ressources et ça c'est bien démontré il
ya pas de doute sur ce constat là est ce
que le capitalisme au sens large est
responsable de tous âges pas certaine
est ce que le capitalisme sauvage je
fais des gosses ça j'en suis certaine or
nous on serait tous si elle me l'avait
pas dit je vais jamais pu deviner quand
dre lise méthode était unique aux
féministes engagées avec un intérêt pour
l'anarchisme quand elle était étudiante
madame andrée lise méthot elle a décidé
de changer le système de l'intérieur en
fondant la plus importante plateforme
d'investissement en technologies vertes
au pays kir 500 millions de dollars sous
gestion
cycle capital
maintenant j'ai découvert que un des
outils puissants de changement dans nos
sociétés à nous nos sociétés
capitalistes c'est l'argent avant l'âge
de 35 ans il y avait rien qui a indiqué
que j'allais faire ça absolument rien en
fait j'avais aucun intérêt pour ça j'ai
même coulis mon cours d'analysé
économique pour un génial
bien
[Rires]
j'ai réalisé que le capital de risque
est un outil puissant de changement on
investit sur des personnes sur un
potentiel plutôt qu'investir sur des
chiffres qui sont déjà complets quand
vous avez c'est dans une entreprise que
peu de revenus parce que vous pensez
qu'elle va changer le monde vous avez
c'est pas sur les résultats financiers
de l'entreprise
vous investissez sur la personne qui est
en train de vous expliquer comment
accomplir son rêve je comprenais qu'en
s'intéressant cette question là on est
en train de définir quelles sont les
technologies qui allait propulser une
économie plus verte
les partisans la croissance verte disque
peut-être que le capitalisme n'est pas
parfait mais on n'a pas le temps en deux
pôles luxe de jeter le système par tard
que d'en créer un nouveau bon c'est
qu'on pourrait effectivement en l'espace
de quelques décennies
transformer une civilisation pour la
réorienter vers quelque chose de
complètement différent c'est très très
optimiste ça c'est très optimiste je
suis d'accord et à certains moments je
désespère totalement bon maintenant le
fait de continuer parce que en gros ce
que nous que nous propose des défenseurs
de la croissance verte et me dise où on
n'a pas réussi jusqu'ici à le faire ce
découplage notre croissance jusqu'ici
n'a pas été vaine mais elle va l'être un
bon mais ce qu'on constate c'est que
concrètement du coup la destruction
s'accélère malheureusement je pense que
l'avenir va nous donner raison et que de
plus en plus ce système avoir du mal à
se maintenir en fait qui va buter sur
ses propres limites on a un système qui
va peut être capable de nourrir c'est le
système il va être il va servir surtout
essayer d'entretenir un peu ce qu'il
veut encore être entretenue mais on va
beaucoup de mal à générer de quoi vivre
en fait donc ça c'est ça va être des
moments qui vont forcer en fait la mise
en question de ce système là d'une façon
dure malheureusement c'est sûr que ça va
être beau beaucoup plus violent et
beaucoup plus désagréable que une
stratégie qui consisterait à dire
aujourd'hui on réfléchit on regarde ce
qu'on peut faire pour arrêter le
désastre
je vais discuter de tout ça avec
marie-josée prix vick qui connaît très
bien le secteur financier dans une
ancienne vie elle était analyste
financière et à le travailler pour des
entreprises cotées en bourse elle peut
tout à fait trouver son compte en
finance du classique pour donner plus de
sens à sa carrière elle le choisit de se
consacrer à l'investissement responsable
bien avant l'engouement actuel pour la
finance verte est ce qu'on devrait
changer de modèle économique
j'aimerais seule réponse que
[Musique]
oui absolument s'il n'y avait rien n'a
changé on serait dans un modèle parfait
entre guillemets et régénératif et les
générations futures aurait aucun souci
de leurs capacités de subvenir à leurs
besoins alors c'est pas le corps donc je
pense que oui effectivement il ya des
choses à changer de là à mettre le
système capitaliste à la poubelle
je ne suis pas partisane nécessairement
de cette option là est ce qu'il ya un
système une solution qui existe je suis
pas sûr je sais qu'on parle de plus en
plus de peut-être de décroissance on
parle de beignets ou on balise le
développement économique je pense que ça
c'est une très belle façon
d'entreprendre le développement
économique
l'économie du big bang c'est un concept
qu'on doit à l'économiste britannique
kate world le beigne c'est la zone de
développement économique qu'on devrait
viser pour combler les besoins humains
tout en restant à l'intérieur des
limites biophysique que la terre est
capable de nous fournir
ya des pays qui respectent les minutes
des notaires mais où les gens vivent
dans des conditions difficiles comme au
sri lanka ya aussi des pays qui comblent
presque parfaitement les besoins humains
comme ici au canada mais qui fracassent
les limites écologiques
jusqu'à maintenant qu' aucun pays qui
réussit à atteindre l équilibre de la
zone habitable du bugue
ce qu'il faut surtout éviter ces des
grands fossés de rémunération que par
exemple mon confort à moi de départ de
la vie d'être quelqu'un d'autre sur
cette planète
si on a pu croître comme on a cru en
occident c'est précisément parce qu'on a
maintenus dans des formes de sous
développement des pays du sud
pour remettre en question la
consommation ça c'est clair net et
précis pour moi
aux premiers gestes premier mouvement ça
suffit il faut qu'on produise moins il
faudrait revenir à ce dont on a besoin
j'ai redistribuer ça autrement la
deuxième chose c'est partager beaucoup
plus ce qu'il nous faut pour vivre
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui est la troisième chose c'est
d'en décider ensemble salifou des
impératifs qu'on puisse en décider en
imaginer un système économique dans
lequel on n'est pas orientée vers le
toujours plus c'est extrêmement facile
mais aucun système dans l'histoire de
l'humanité qui a été orientée comme une
ode vers l'accumulation permanente c'est
une innovation propre au système
capitaliste occidental qui émerge
rouille trois quatre siècles qui est
orienté vers ce toujours plus
mais ça on dirait que c'est souvent
interprétés comme ça il faudrait
retourner à l'âge de pierre on vous dit
ça mais plusieurs fois par jour
j'imagine
est ce que c'est ce qu'il faut faire bah
non il ya des travaux de mesures là
dessus sur ce qu'il faudrait que ça nous
ramènerait quel genre de niveau de vie
tout ça en général ce conte ce qu'on lit
là c'est que ça pourrait nous ramener à
des modes de vie qu'on a pu connaître au
milieu du xxème siècle donc on pourrait
garantir à tous les humains aujourd'hui
donc et on est nombreux une vie tout à
fait digne sur le plan matériel sans
produire comme on produit donc en fait
c'est un système qui lui-même ça qu'il
faut réaliser avec le capitalisme c'est
qu' il n'est pas orienté satisfaction
des besoins il est orienté vers
l'accumulation de l'accumulation
d'argent et à tout prix c'est ça que
c'est ça qu'il oriente donc on vise plus
la surconsommation que la concerne la
consommation m on vise surtout la
surproduction c'est cela c'est parce que
dans le discours écologiste actuelle on
met beaucoup beaucoup finalement la
responsabilité sur le dos de chacun et
chacune il faut consommer moins c'est à
regarder ça détruit mois mais on
consomme autant parce qu'on est pris
dans un système qui lui-même produit
beaucoup qui a absolument besoin qu'on
consomme pour que ce pour se reproduire
ça s'appelle j'ai mes petites bricoles
un capitalisme
vous ferez quoi étape par étape les
moyens de réparer le capitalisme pour
qu'il fasse du bien à la planète je
pense que la première chose il de rendre
transparent que les décisions soient
claires que les processus soit
transparent que les actionnaires et le
public en général puissent voir comment
les décisions se prennent la deuxième
chose c'est aligné les succès avec les
intérêts qu'on veut car si le succès
n'est que seulement la réussite
financière mais les patrons les
patronnes du capitalisme vont travailler
pour la réussite financière ici le
succès c'était aussi la diminution du
co2 l'augmentation de la place des
femmes et que les grands patrons étaient
bien rémunérés et si les conseils
d'administration avec ces résultats là
mais je pense qu'il reste qu'on appelle
de façon très classe et un alignement
d'intérêt des carottes riz faute il faut
que la carotte soit attrayante parce que
le bâton s'est jamais suffisamment est
ce que les gouvernements devraient quand
même joué un peu de bon temps dans ce
système avec gouvernement aura le rôle
extrêmement important le gouvernement et
le régulateur
ces solutions de ça porteront pas juste
avec les règles classiques du marché que
nous offre le capitalisme ça prend donc
dontreix et sociale des états qui
doivent lui suffirait
des fois on se retrouve devant un
produit au magasin qui est tellement peu
cher qu'on se demande si on paie le vrai
prix si sa production a impliqué des
coûts environnementaux ou humain qui
n'apparaissent pas dans le prix sur
l'étiquette en ce moment il ya plein de
gens qui essaient de transformer notre
modèle économique pour que ces coûts
deviennent visibles un système qui
avantagerait les entreprises qui font
preuve de transparence c'est exactement
la mission que marie-josée prix vix est
donné les investisseurs mettent de plus
en plus aussi les fournisseurs de
capitaux donc les banques les compagnies
d'assurances intègre les enjeux esg dans
leurs prises de décisions d'allocation
de capital des enjeux de nature
environnementale sociale ou de
gouvernance la réglementation se
développe on la voit en europe on la
voit dans d'autres juridictions aussi ça
veut dire que bientôt les entreprises
vont être obligés de divulguer leurs
performances au loire non performance
environnementale un peu comme d'ouvrir
leur les pleurs les comptables dans ses
partitions et c'est exactement sur
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à une
divulgation est vieux on parle d'eux
vraiment un changement de paradigme un
changement de philosophie et on parle
d'intégrer la notion de développement
durable dans le modèle d'affaires même
de l'entreprise donc dans ce qu'elle
fait et donc comment elle le fait
peut-être qu'on oppose trop souvent
capitalisme sauvage et des croissances
moyennes dangereuses comme s'ils avaient
bien entre les deux extrêmes
mais s'il ya une chose que l'urgence
climatique nous enseigne c'est que
toutes les solutions efficaces sont
nécessaires
peut-être que la réponse se trouve dans
un grand effort de sobriété
combinée à une économie au service de
tous les humains et de la santé de la
planète la seule option qui n'est plus
sur la table c'est de ne rien faire même
face à des enjeux qui peuvent paraître
insurmontables où on gère l'enjeu tous
ensemble et on s'en sort tous ensemble
ou alors on s'en sortira pas personne
c'est un peu tanné d'entendre parler ah
oui oui je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui parlent moi maintenant je veux
juste voir les gens qu'il faut puis une
des raisons pourquoi je tends capital de
risque je suis dans la technologie c'est
parce que ces gens leurs fonds ou
essayent de faire si je pense que le
problème réglé à tous niveaux atteints
paquebot steglitz toile puis faut que
les gouvernements aient le même genre de
pensée donc on ait envie oui il ya de
l'espoir en fin d'enquêté de la vie
humaine n'y a pas de raison de de céder
complètement de vaud désespoir par
contre surtout pas essayer de sauver
cette civilisation elle est complètement
auto destructrice le plan écologique
elle est très injuste sur le plan social
c'est la dernière des choses à faire
[Musique]